[Music]
everything in life is a negotiation
when you cross the street is a
negotiation getting your coffee at
starbucks
is a negotiation you're probably in
three to seven negotiations
every single day your life could be in a
completely different place
just by improving how you negotiate
negotiators are working around the clock
the deadline for execution has passed
with us now to help break down the
investigation
fbi special agent hostage negotiator
christopher voss
my role as a hostage negotiator was to
connect
authentically with the victim the
victim's family and with the hostage
taker
everybody really deserves to have
somebody
hear what they have to say
in my master class i'm going to give you
all the strategies
and tactics that i developed as one of
the top hostage negotiators
in the world you're going to learn
everything from bargaining to reading
body language
to the neuroscience that you can use to
literally bend people's reality
you know negotiation is letting the
other side have your way
so mirroring creates the opportunity for
them actually to present you with your
deal
only they thought it was their idea it's
just a simple repetition of the last
one to three words of what somebody said
you've got the actual recording on the
chase manhattan bank robbery hostage
taking we've got a van
out here know anything about it you guys
chase my driver away
we chased your driver away my training
was the mirror and the bank robber
started blurting out stuff they had no
intention of saying
people love to be married they love to
be encouraged to go on
these skills help you improve your life
sometimes people say to me these tools
are just manipulation it's about
win lose that is not the case great
negotiation is about
great collaboration why does it matter
to you
you should get better at negotiation
because however your life is now
you can do better i'm chris voss
and this is my master class
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you